the shaky science show clips
no exactly and personalized medicine is
something that's also i find really
interesting because you're right we are
all different we have different um
genetic variations we all have different
environmental factors that we're exposed
to we do different jobs we eat different
things and so i guess another question
um is if we are going to kind of strive
for like personalized medicine what kind
of things would we need to do in terms
of biomarkers like i suppose the by the
way phrasing it is what would be like
the gold standard for biomarkers to be
able to achieve personalized medicine
yeah i think that's an interesting
question i mean you could imagine
optimizing the aging biome
but one thing about aging biomarkers is
that
we tend to think that biologic aging
behaves like chronologic aging you know
chronologication is just measured by
time and goes steadily up
my guess with these biologic aging
markers is that's not what's happening
that they're oscillating
you know and then depending on
how much sleep you got you know whether
you ate healthy did you go for a run
you have the
a virus
and you might have be biologically 10
years different from one
from one two week period to the next
and so i i sort of see it as you know
as you get older that oscillation may be
increasing and eventually you cross some
threshold and
then you're also
hyperglycemic or something you get
diabetes so
i think that we really need to look
longitudinally at these biomarkers
because one time point may not give you
a really good determination of what what
your biologic age is
uh so if you're optimizing to that you
know it might work but the oscillation
may cause problems so
what we're trying to do right now is you
know for things like vitamin a we know
what the toxicity markers are so we look
at those
uh and but we don't really know what
vitamin d does to aging so we're we're
looking at we're trying to
identify the right efficacy marker too
so we're looking at inflammatory markers
and other things but
um yeah i think that that's one
challenge right now to personalize drug
dosing
uh is that we don't always know what we
want to optimize for in the blood
so there's a little bit of
science that has to go in and figure
that out too
so what um are the kind of main
biomarkers that you think at the moment
are most effective so i know there's a
lot of talk about using the epigenetic
um agent clock so would you be able to
explain a bit what that is
yeah so uh you know by even around 2010
everyone was saying that the search for
aging biomarkers is basically a failure
you know we have things like walking
speed and grip strength and time get up
and go and
a few other things that work
particularly well in elderly populations
but in terms of molecular biomarkers
none of them were that predictive even
telomere length i mean it does have some
correlation with with life expectancy
but it's not that strong
what happened is that uh people like
steve horvath and others
uh they started collecting really deep
data sets of genome-wide dna methylation
uh and then
had the person's age and so they put age
into the computer and then had the
computer use machine learning to
optimize
uh the the state of methylation and all
these different sites in the genome uh
to predict a person's age so if your age
is 50 and the biologic age says you're
45
you know that really what that is is the
error
in the algorithm because the algorithm
is trying to predict chronologic age but
the argument is that the error is there
because it's not really can't really
measure chronologic age it's measuring
biologic age and so
what that's saying is that you're
actually aging very well you're only 45
when you actually have lived 50 years
uh and that now there's a whole range of
different evolved methylation clocks
that and that's one of the things we're
using in singapore i'll say however that
it's still unclear whether there's
anything special about methylate dna
methylation
there are clocks based on
transcriptomics they're clocks based on
microbiome now they're clocks based on
metabolomics
uh and so
it may be that and like i said there's a
facial pattern clock
it may be that anything that you can get
enough complex data and enough people
and use the right ai
you can predict biologic aids from so i
i think that's still an open question is
there anything special about methylation
um
but were you so we're using the facial
pattern stuff we were you doing complete
blood counts because there's a company
called gerald that's helped can do
biologic aids from that data
we're collecting accelerometry data
we're collecting dexa scans and immune
markers and some of the more classic
clinical markers
uh and the idea is to really merge all
that together and see you know
what what we're getting out of it and
are we looking at
you know several sides of the same coin
are we looking at
completely different things which would
be kind of scary so i hope that's not
the case so
it's um
the first step is really to to bring
these different biomarkers together and
see how they interact
that's a really good answer so um i
agree i think the improvements as well
that it seems like every every few
months has a much like improvement upon
these different clocks in terms of their
accuracy and their ability to
integrate the different markets together
and so i guess one um
issue in terms of being able to make
these
biomarkers scalable is to have a kind of
cost effective
um by marker and some say the facial
patterns is something that anyone could
just take a photo it seems quite easily
scalable but in terms of like these more
amex approaches how scalable do you
think they are
first of all the collab we the
collaborator we work with on the facial
pattern is jackie han
uh uh peking university and uh
it's actually uh was originally
optimized in the han chinese ethnicity
the uh
it doesn't work with just a phone
picture yet you need to re do a
three-dimensional reconstruction that
your phone can't fight it's getting
close but can't quite do
um so it's not as simple but i think
phones will get there and you know the
technology may improve to use
phone data as well there are other
people that have tried to generate
clocks from phone pictures as well um
the uh
but you know the you know the other
stuff methylation can now be done from
saliva
uh so you know with the with the that's
why we chose the particular methylation
clock we did is you could send an
envelope with a piece of paper
along with
akg this is for the company and you can
spit on the piece of paper and send it
back in and the dna is stable and you
know so that's not that's very scalable
uh if you have to take a blood draw it
gets a little bit more complicated and
we've just completely rejected anything
that requires biopsies because
while they may be more informative i can
certainly do a lot with biopsies i can't
people aren't going to get muscle
biopsies just won't do it so
and you can't scale it anyway so it's i
think that
we're willing to look at those more
complex things or things like dexa
scanning but
that's really for more for research
purposes the main goal of the biomarkers
is you know again something that
everybody can do